so it's great to see you here for the  raids to premiere tonight what was it  like being part of that movie and also  you're also in the killer's which is  here only killers was premiered last  night well actually this is my first  time to in Sundance but as for film this  is actually my my third because last  year I work with good Garrett for VHS -  yeah I was screen also last year but we  could make it because me and Gabe was  shooting the radio  so it's very exciting is here I mean  Sundance is is big for people back home  so it's very proud and what we expect  for your character in the raid - um  there's gonna be a twist for my  character so watch out for that one  does that mean we might see we're  getting rights free um I don't know  about that I'll let you do all speaking  it  thanks so much lemme just be here  you